what is your process for all about
liking you taking long walks and the
forest concept I mean we are just
observing people in daily life it what
do you do when you're in that space um
yeah I don't know I don't even sort of
like writers block necessarily but it is
sort of like that I mean in the case of
working with Ryan on the next on the
follow up movie to some guy who kills
people it's about us kind of finding the
project that we both feel in other words
I guess it would be slightly different
if I was just sitting down and writing
something because I could say okay right
this is what's on my mind now I'll see
if I can I'm feeling you know whatever
I'm feeling so let me try to find
something that fits that movie with Ryan
because we had such an interesting
collaboration even though some guy who
kills people and the script was so I was
so sort of wedded to it I was so like
this is the thing I need to make you
know Ryan is went through his own
process to make to write that thing I
wasn't there during the writing of that
movie i came in at the end when it was
already sort of realized ryan has to go
through his own process of him fine so
not only am I like in that lindos he is
to you know he's trying to find the
thing so sometimes he'll throw out an
idea just working it out like what about
this thing and I'll be like oh this is
fantastic this is exactly what I want to
do but he may not be as crazy about it
as another idea which I'm not so much
into so there's this weird sort of
process we're going through now or it's
like what about this can we show each
other what's interesting and these ideas
that we're floating about i don't know i
think that the only way to get through
the process is to I think sometimes it's
helpful doing like for example trailer
hitch it's helpful doing trail it's
helpful doing small things I think even
doing an interview doing a really short
it doesn't have to be a short film it
could just be like a one minute long
thing where you go out and shoot
something I think the more that you can
sort of exercise that muscle that
filmmaking muscle and actually go out
and try some things like for example
like my my sister-in-law's had
birthday and I'm never really good at
coming up with presents for bragging
I'll know what to buy anybody in a I
can't write a card but I can't make
these little like like almost like South
Park style animations that I make into a
card you know and that is a creative
like making it like spending a couple
hours making out like a little animated
card for my sister-in-law is a really
good way of like oiling up lubing up the
gears so I think a right like they'll
say a writer writes like the important
things if you're a writer you get up and
you write even if you don't know what
you're writing about just to kind of
because chances are if you just keep
doing this thing it is the equivalent of
taking a long walk in the woods it's
like you're shooting or you're typing
while you're doing it like something
will come out a word or phrase an image
will come and it'll be like hopefully
that'll trigger the larger the larger
thing I think that's the way to do it
otherwise all i do is brewed or worry if
you're just worried I'm going on like
nothing comes from that I've done enough
at that I do that anyway so I think it's
important to just go most like shoot it
out or type it out you know because it's
out there it's just you've got to arrive
at it and sitting about it and worrying
about it isn't going to get you there
necessarily also I should be meditating
more I learned trick what's not really
trick as a whole lifetime it's a whole
life experience but like one of the
things when I was hunting for ideas was
I was learning about David Lynch and and
transit then Transcendental Meditation
you know TM just this whole other thing
but like one of the reasons that one of
the reasons why David Lynch is such a
proponent of meditating is that that's
where the ideas surface in other words
you just calm your mind down so that
you're not like all the days isn't
spinning through your mind then the
things that are naturally important to
you the idea of being with things that
are naturally interesting will bubble up
and then ideas come from that you know
so that's another thing that I need to
continue to do I did started doing it
actually around the time is making mega
shark vs giant octopus doing meditation
and it really helped a lot of things
came out of that so since everybody's
process is different but it's it
certainly is a process I wish it was so
fast one
you